wang shuelien is 44
and looks forward to retiring at the age
of 50 but she may need to wait a little
longer the chinese government is set to
raise the age of retirement by at least
five years just one of the policy
changes expected in response to the
country's rapidly ageing society
i couldn't accept my retirement being
delayed much longer
i was very concerned when i heard this
news
according to the results of a once in a
decade census china's population
is greying and growing at its slowest
pace in decades
since 2010 it expanded by 5.38
to 1.41 billion people falling short of
the government target of 1.42
analysts say china is facing a
demographic time bomb
and the numbers may be lower than
reported
in the 1980s 25 million babies were born
every year last year the figure was 12
million
even if you believe this number is less
than half
of what it was the workforce is
declining quickly
and china is losing its economic
vitality the population is expected to
shrink as early
as 2022 this will impact china's ability
to compete with other countries
china's labor force will lose an
estimated 35 million workers over the
next five years
people are also living longer putting
immense pressure on china's pension and
health system
almost 20 percent of the population are
over the age of 60.
china's aging crisis is made worse by
the slowing birth rate
families are having fewer children
despite government efforts to boost the
birth rate
by ending the one child policy in 2016.
the rising cost of living is one but not
the only reason women are having fewer
children
the real problem is actually the
long-term career
there is no really social arrangement
or government support for women with
children
and how their career should be rebooted
the government is under pressure to
abandon child limits altogether
some say it's too late populations in
china's northeast are already shrinking
beijing is focusing on what it says are
positive changes
increased urbanization and higher levels
of education
it's dismissed claims its census figures
are inaccurate
wong shuiyan accepts that policy changes
are coming
but hopes workers like her will end up
better
and not worse off katrina you al jazeera
beijing